advice happened it happens that I write
too small font please feel free to stop
me and let me know it's just uh as I
said every after a few lectures I
stopped uh I I start to forget about it
so please remind me
um
so okay so I guess
first let me briefly reviewed the last
lecture just very quick so last lecture
we talked about these two important
Concepts
um under fitting and overfitting so I
got some so so here you know our goal is
to make the organization work right so
we want to generalize two unseen
examples
so
um and last time we talked about two
possible reasons
for why your test error is not good
enough right so one possible reason is
overfitting so overfitting means that
your tuning hour is actually pretty good
your children loss is pretty small but
their test loss is pretty high
so and we have discussed the possible uh
reasons for why
um you can have overfitting and two
possible reasons are if maybe you have
two complex of model for example last
time we discussed that you know if you
use a 50 degree polynomial for this very
very small data set where you only have
like four examples then you may overfit
or maybe you don't have enough data
right if you have more and more data
um if you have like a million data then
a 50 degree polynomial wouldn't be a
problem
and also we discussed that
um another reason underfading so under
fitting is much easier understating in
some sense basically just means that you
don't have small enough tuning loss or
tuning error right so your model is just
not powerful enough so that you cannot
even fit to the training data you have
so so and in some sense these are kind
of like two complementary situations
right so in this case you probably want
to make your model more expressive and
in this case you maybe you want to make
your model less expressive
or less complex so we use this word in
your complex expressive you know a lot
you know without the formal definition
right so we say some models are more
complex you know some models are less
complex typically you know you can
somehow feel it right so a fifth degree
polynomial probably is more complex than
linear model but actually you know if
you really want to have a you know
concrete definition it becomes a little
bit tricky right so what is the right
complexity measure of the model someone
asks about that as well in the last
lecture you know and the answer is that
there's no
um Universal measure for what's the
right complex model complexity measure
and and there are a few you know
um
um kind of like a complex financials
people often use you know they all have
their kind of like particular strands
and they are like and and also like
there's no
um you know real kind of like a formal
Theory to say which one is better so
these are kind of complex measures that
can be you know
um theoretically kind of Justified in
certain cases but they are not kind of
like a
um Universal so so what are the complex
measures so I'm just listing a few just
to follow kind of like for your
knowledge in some sense so
so I guess the most obvious one is how
many parameters they are right so if you
have more parameters than your model
might be more complex
and this is you know very intuitive
however the limitation here is that
maybe you have a lot of parameters but
you actually the the effective
complexity of the model is very very low
maybe all the parameters are very very
small then maybe you can say in this
case maybe the complexity is actually
not as big as your thoughts so so to
kind of like a deal with this kind of
like scaling thing right so what do you
feel complex your all your parameters
are basically zero even though you have
a million parameters then people
consider kind of like Norms of the
parameters right
okay
but this may not be no this is actually
typical the Norms of parameters is
actually very good uh they are very good
complex measures for linear models
um and and this there's no basically
before deep learning kind of like uh
arised
um um like uh you know before I think we
are using Norms as complex measures a
lot
um and still we use them in some cases
but these also have some you know
limitations for example sometimes you
may for example
would be that you have a very low Norm a
low Norm solution and you add some
random kind of like a noise to the to
the model and when you add the noise you
make the norm bigger but actually the
noise doesn't really change the
complexity right because you add some
noise and when you take the Matrix
modification you average all the noise
to some extent so so these are you know
there are also this kind of like issues
so some of the other kind of more more
than complex measures people have
considered uh are for example something
like lipsteousness
right whether your model is
ellipselessness uh it's Ellipsis or
maybe your model is smooth enough and
here I'm using the word smooth uh you
know relatively kind of like um informal
way you know you could mean this could
mean the bound and the secondary
derivative it could mean the bonus third
of derivative something like that if
your model is kind of like no it's kind
of like oscillating or kind of
fluctuating a lot maybe that means it's
not very complex
um and there are other kind of like a
complex measures for example how
environment your model is with respect
to for example certain translations
certain environments
um that you should have in a data set
for example whether your model is
environment to data augmentation
um but in general there's no kind of
like a very kind of like established
theory on what is exactly the right
complex measure and sometimes it also
depends on the data as I would see as
you will see today so so if you if your
data you know
sometimes for you know for example
suppose your data
um um for example
let's talk about Norms right so
different Norms you know what what type
of norms are you talking about L1 Norm
L2 Norm sometimes L2 Norm is the right
complex measure for certain type of data
and sometimes L1 Norm is the right
complex measure for a certain type of
data so basically I don't think this is
kind of like there's anything super
concrete we can
um like it's not like I have a kind of
like just a fixed like a suggestion for
you to consider so so in some sense you
should just keep this in mind and kind
of like a kind of consider them you know
when you
um when you do your own data set so
um
so so this is the um okay so now we have
to discuss the complexity measures and
now that in the the the the the rest of
the lecture I think I'm going to cover
two things so one thing is that so once
you have some kind of like guess on
what's the right complex measure you are
looking for how do you make the complex
measure small right so so
um how do you encourage the model to
have small complexity right so it's
easier to do this because you just
change how how many kind of neurons or
how many kind of like
hidden variables in deep networks where
you can change the number of parameters
but if you want to change the norm what
you do so that's called regularization
I'm going to discuss that in the first
half of the lecture and then in the
second half of lecture I'm going to talk
about you know how do you
um I'm going to talk about you know some
kind of more General ml device for
example how do you tune your hyper
parameters like when you do
regularization or when you kind of like
choose your model complexity right you
can use a lot of hyper parameters
meaning you're going to choose how many
parameters you have you're going to
choose you know how strong your
organization is so so how do you tune
your hyper parameters
um and on what data set you should tune
your hybrid parameters and at the end
I'm going to probably spend 30 minutes
on even more applied angle about some
email or device right so like for
example how do you design the ml system
you know from scratch you know there are
a lot more things in reality more than
what you're doing research
um so so that part will I'll use some
slides to talk about some general no
ideas on how to design ml system uh in
in the in the in reality
so so that's the general kind of
introduction of this course of this
lecture
um I'm going to start with
regularization I need questions so far
foreign
I think we have probably mentioned this
um I think in the sometimes like in the
previous kind of lectures because just
because you know
um
just because you know uh we have
mentioned this you know informally so by
regularization mostly we just mean that
you add some additional term in your
training loss to encourage low
complexity models so
um so for example you so we use J of
theta as our training loss and then you
consider this so-called regularized loss
where you add a term
Lambda times R Theta
so here this R Theta is often called the
regularizer
and Lambda is you know I think there are
different names for this but you could
call it regularization strengths or
regularization coefficient
regularization parameter regularization
strengths whatever you call it if let's
call it regularization strength
so this Lambda is a scalar and R of
theta is a function of data
um which um which will change as data
changes so
um
and this and the goal of this Rotator is
to you know either additional kind of
like encouragement to find model Theta
such that are obviously small so for
example typical R of theta could be
um
something like you know L2
regularization so you say R Theta one
possible choice is that you take this is
probably the most common choice
um you take the L2 North square and you
multiply about half the half doesn't
really matter this is just some kind of
conversion
um you know that because anyway you can
multiply a Lambda in front of it so so
whether you have half or not here you
know we just change your choice of
Lambda but just uh this is you know
um just a convention
um and so so this is called you know L2
regularization also in deep learning
people called Ray Decay there is a
reason why people call it way Decay I
guess probably I wouldn't have time to
discuss it today so you know the
lecturer knows there's a very short
paragraph you can see actually if you
use this regularization and update rule
will look like a very Decay so there's
one step in the update rule where you
Decay your parameter will shrink your
parameter by scalar so but anyway so you
know it's just a name like either it's
called vertical you call it Auto
regularization
so let's play one of the pretty common
one so and and you can see that if you
add this thing to your loss function and
you're minimizing your loss function so
then you are trying to make
both the last month and also make the
the L2 Norm of your parameter small and
the Lambda in some senses kind of kind
of like controlling the trade-off
between these two terms right if you
take Lambda 2 back then you only focus
on the regularization you just only
focus on low low Norm solution but maybe
you don't fit your data very well if you
take Lambda to be you know for example
zero literally zero then you are not
using your regularization you are just
only fitting your data and actually when
you make the Lambda very very small this
can still uh do something right so even
say let's say Lambda is .0001 Right very
small
still this might do something because
maybe they are multiple Theta such that
J of theta is really really close to
zero or maybe even literally close zero
so so if you don't have this then you
are not doing any type working right if
you don't have if you literally make
lambda zero then you are just picking
one of the solution where J Theta is
zero but you don't know which one you
pick but even as long as you add a
little bit of organization then you are
using this as a tie breaker in some
sense so so you are finding some
solutions such as J Theta is very very
small but you use the the r the norm as
a tiebreaker uh among all of the
solutions that have very small tuning
laws
so so this is probably the most typical
regularization people use and another
one is the following so you can take R
Theta
to be
uh the so-called zero zero Norm of the
parameter but actually this is not
really a norm this is just a notation so
this is really just defined to be the
number of non-zeros
in the model in in cell
so you count how many non-zero entries
in Theta and that's the uh that's what
this notation is for some sometimes
people call it zero Norm but it's
actually not a norm uh literally it's
just the number of non-zeros in a
parameter and sometimes people call it
sparsity
because you know if you have very few
non-zero entries then it sparse
otherwise it's it's dense so if you add
this to the the thing then you're gonna
have a different effect you are trying
to say that I'm going to find a model
such that the number of non-zeros in it
is small and this is particularly
meaningful for linear models in the
following sense because if you think of
the state as a linear model then say you
have Theta transpose X right suppose you
have a linear model and then what is
this this is really just some of say the
i x i
from one to D and then you can see that
the number of non-zeros is really how
many
if suppose you have like s non-zero
answers in Theta that means that you are
using only s of the coordinates of X
size
so basically the number of non-zeros is
in Theta is the number of coordinates or
number of features you are using uh from
x i
right so you can imagine that maybe for
example for some applications you have a
lot of like a coordinates in our
features in your input features right so
you have so many different kind of like
informations but you don't know which
one you should use to predict right for
example suppose you want to predict
house the price of a house then you have
so many different features but some
features may not be that useful so then
you can imagine that that could be a
situation where you should use this as a
regularizer because you want to say I
want to use as few features as possible
but also I want to make sure my training
loss is good right so I want to find the
simplest
explanations of the of the existing data
or simplest meaning that you want to use
as few features as possible
so and and once you find this Theta such
that Theta sparse right so suppose you
have a Theta such that you only have a
few non-zeros uh in Theta then you are
selecting the right feature so in some
sense you know you have a sparse model
means you are selecting
the features
right because those non-zeros
corresponds to its features that are
selected by the model so so people often
call this kind of like a feature
Selections in some in certain kind of
contexts
so
um however I mean you may have realized
that this
regularizer as a function of theta this
sparsity one is not uh differentiable
right so you're just counting how many
non-zeros they are right so suppose you
have one suppose you have like you have
one entry that is um maybe it's just
zero zero zero right you do an if the
testimo change in this uh in any of the
coordinates you're going to change the
this function the value of this function
by a lot so that's why it's not
differentiable right a differentiable
function should satisfy that if you
change
Theta if the decimal is small then you
should change the function output by a
small amount but actually here if you
currently the sparse is zero but if you
change the state a little bit your
sparsity becomes one so you can have
infinite testimony small changes to make
the regularizer value change by a large
amount so that's that's why it's not
differentiable so so it's not because
because it's not differentiable then um
you don't have gradients you don't have
like a derivatives so that's that cause
the problem in in using this so so
basically even though I told you this is
a regularizer but literally in reality
nobody use this exactly in their
algorithm because if you use it you get
this you know you put it here but this
term has no gradient how do you optimize
it
so so if because it's non-diffensible so
then what we will do is that
um you like you change um you have a
surrogate so this is a typical surrogate
um the reason why this is surrogate is a
little bit kind of tricky
um but um
um but you know but this is you know has
been your surrogate for the sparsity so
this is a differentiable surrogate
um
for the for the sparsity of the model
so you use the one Norm so here one Norm
just means the the sum of the apps value
is the sum of the absolute value of each
chord
so and you can see you know I wouldn't
attempt to give you a very formal
justification for why this is so good
um why this is a good Target for the
zero
um you know one reason could be that you
know you can see at least one Norm is
closer to than two Norm to zero Norm
right Y is close to closer to zero than
two and another reason probably you know
this is not really very solid
mathematical reason but it's just to
give you some you know intuition so
suppose you think of theta as a as a
vector in zero one suppose you really
just have a binary Vector then indeed
this is equals to this
right so that's that's probably another
kind of intuitive reason why they are
somewhat kind of like related but you
know you can see a lot of problems with
this argument right so why I'm assuming
Theta is between is only taking value
from zero and one right so if they are
from zero and two then these two are no
longer like related and more so
um so so I'm not saying that this is
really a good argument for why they are
related so so if you really want to I'll
say they are related um or this is a
good surrogate I think you have to go
through more much more mass
um any questions so far
regularizer with the second nominal
regularly you mean yes okay yes that's
what I'm gonna do next
so
um
all right so right so that's a great
question so why
um you want to encourage sparsity
um sometimes and sometimes you want to
encourage the two Norms to be small
right so let's answer that question you
know let's think of this as a as a
surrogate for the sparsity so the
question I'm trying to answer is why
sometimes this is better sometimes this
is better so in some sense the the
fundamental reason is just that you know
in some sense the regularization or
another way to think about
regularization instead of just
encouraging low complexity is that
regularization can also improve can also
impose structures kind of like prior
beliefs about the Theta so so this is
probably another
at least you know
one of the other ways to think of
requisition this also imposes
structures
and this what are the structures the
structures you know probably sometimes
units you have a prior belief
so for example suppose you believe you
you have a prior belief because of
domain knowledge right so such that
um you somehow believe that uh Theta
sparse
right so in in smart SATA
then in this case you probably should
just use R Theta is the the one Norm or
the zero Norm
just because you believe that your model
is sparse why not just encourage that
right so so this you know when you have
this belief then you should say okay so
if you if you encourage the one normally
you're you're in some sense you you
limit your search space right so yeah
like you limit your search space before
you are searching over all possible
parameters and now you're only searching
over low Norm low one non-parameters and
because you believe that your true model
is in is is having low Norm then even
narrowing the search space is always new
never narrowing your search space is
always helping you because uh you didn't
lose anything right because you know you
know that all every model you excluded
are not going to be uh the right
solution so so you never search space
the search the new search space still
has the right model then why not do it
so so that's another interpretation of
um of the uh of the regularizer so it's
trying to it can impose additional prior
belief
um uh in the in the in the structure of
the model right so if you believe in one
Norm then you should you encourage well
not or whatnot if you believe that your
true model has a small L2 Norm then you
should encourage
um small L2 naught and and you know if
if you go into more mathematical uh
Theory I think L2 Norm typically
corresponds to situations where you
believe that all the features are useful
but you have to use them you know uh in
a combination right so you have to use
each of the features you know a little
bit an L1 Norm or l0 Norm typically
corresponds to situations where you
believe only a subset of the features
are meaningful and you should discard
other ones because other ones are just
kind of like are there to confuse you in
substance so so if you believe your
model is his sparse you should use L1
norm and if you believe your model
shouldn't be sparse then typically
people use l tuna
so and
and if you have a linear model so
suppose you have a suppose you have a
linear model
and and then this this law this loss if
you use this L1 normalizer this is
called lasso
I guess I'm here I'm just the final name
because I think it's probably useful for
to at least a third of this name this
this uh acronym uh was actually I don't
know what it originally stands for but
you know this is uh so like this has
been like there for like 20 or 30 years
which is a very very important algorithm
for linear model you apply L1 uh norm
regularization and it's called lasso in
everyone in machine learning should know
the equity
so
um
right
and taking a little more broader
perspective so
um so if you think about like a
non-linear models like deep learning
models so what are the most popular
regularizers these days I think L1 Norm
is not used very often and actually
pretty much it's never used um you know
I don't know exactly you know how
frequent it is but you know I think
probably less than 10 percent of model
use L1 recognizer maybe even less than
that 10 probably is much overestimate
maybe one percent so
um and but the L2 regularization is
almost always used like even though
sometimes you only use a very weak Auto
regularization indeed I'm talking about
deep learning model so sorry maybe let
me just clarify for for linear models
people tried uh you can try almost
anything anything would be reasonable
and you probably should try all of them
you could try one Norm two norm and
sometimes you can try different Norms
which I didn't write down but you can
try 1.5 Norms something like that so for
nonlinear model for deep learning models
I think basically L2 Norm is something
that you almost always use but you only
use of it with relatively small Lambda
people generally don't use very large
Lambda
I don't know exactly what's the reason
you know um researchers don't really
know that much either but a small Auto
regularization is typically useful for
deep learning and in deep learning I
think some of the other regularizations
you know could be useful for example you
can try to regularize the lipsense of
the model
um and you can try to use data
augmentation which we probably haven't
discussed I'm going to discuss that
um in a later lecture but you can use
data augmentation which tries to
encourage your model to be environment
with respect to a kind of translation
cropping this kind of things for for
images
um I think those are pretty much the the
only regularization techniques in deep
learning
um
yeah
[Applause]
this kind of
pertains to my employer yeah what you
suggest initially using the
and one day to kind of eliminate the
features
that's a very good question so I think
this kind of algorithm was pretty
popular in uh um for before deep
learning era so when you use linear
models I think using L1 to do a
selection and then you use L2 I think
you know I don't know how exactly how
popular they are but this is definitely
one algorithm people try to could you
could try to use
um in deep learning I think it's
probably less likely to be useful you
know but also depends on the situation
for example if you don't have enough
data maybe you are more or less in a
linear model case but you just need the
nonlinearity to help you a little bit
maybe then in that case you should still
mostly use some kind of like more like
linear model type of approach if you are
in the the typical deep learning setting
for example you do for a vision project
right you have like images right as your
inputs I think in those cases you
probably don't want to select your
features first I think all the inputs
are useful like I'm able to use them as
much as possible and you just want to
let the new light works to figure out
what's the best way to use those inputs
any other question by the way this
lecture will be pretty kind of we don't
have a lot of math right most of the
things are about um just uh I I don't
think there's even a theory here
sometimes they're just experiences
because especially if you talk about
um like the more the Machinery in the
last five years right everything seems
to change a little bit right so I like I
cannot say anything with about 100
guarantee I can only say okay it sounds
like people are doing this a lot and
that's that's the best thing I can I can
tell you in some sense
um so so feel free to ask any questions
any other questions
right so and the next thing I'm going to
discuss is the so-called implicit
regulation effect
and um
this does uh
this released more to the the Deep
learning and so one reason uh that
people started to think about this is
that you know I haven't told you what
exactly means so one motivation that
people started to stand up for research
is that people realize that in deep
learning you don't use a lot of
regularization technique right so you
use L2 as I said you only use a weak out
to regularization and and often some of
these latest ones but they only have a
little bit right they can be useful but
people don't necessarily use them very
often so why in deep learning you don't
have to use strong regularization at
least like you can feel that the
regularization stop method stop matter
from that much it still matters when you
really care about the final performance
you care about 95 versus 97 but but you
don't have to even you don't use
regularization sometimes you get
reasonably good performance so so that's
why people are especially with
theoretical researchers people are
wondering why you don't need to use a
strong regularizations in deep learning
and this is particularly mysterious
because in deep learning people are
using over parametrization like we are
we are in this regime where you have
more parameters than the number of
samples we call that in the last lecture
we have drawn this uh double descent
thing right where you have this kind of
things right here is the number of
parameters
and this is the test error
and you know we have kind of discussed
that this peak might be just something
about the sub-optimality of the
algorithm which let's say you don't care
for the moment but at least you have to
care about why here
um why it's go going down you know still
here right so why when you have so many
parameters a lot more parameters you can
still make your model generalized and
and it seems that more and more Paramus
makes it looks better
so so so this the overall primary Choice
regime is kind of mysterious because you
don't use strong regularization but you
can still generalize
so that was the kind of the motivation
for people to study this and people
realized that there's you know even
though in this regime suppose you don't
use any expensive regularizer you don't
you make that lambda zero literally zero
right in this regime still it can
generalize and the reason it can
generalize in many cases is because
um you can still have some implicit
regularization in fact even without
explicit regularizer and where that
effect comes from we know what kind of
make that happen the reason is that
um the optimization process the
optimization algorithm
the optimizers can have a con implicitly
regularize you
so so why this can happen I think the
reason is that let me draw kind of like
illustrative kind of figure which I kind
of like use pretty often so suppose this
is the
let's say this is the the pyramid like
suppose you have a this is the Lost
landscape the Lost surface
so meaning that here is Theta let's say
is one dimensional
and because we are in this deep learning
setting where we have like a non-linear
models and non-convex loss function so
maybe a loss function it looks like this
maybe
so this is the loss function
and you have two maybe you have multiple
Global Minima of your loss function
right so so this is a global minimum
this is a global minimum
and but this but you have multiple
Global minimum in your loss function
however
I'm here I'm talking about trending logs
right if you really look at the test
loss you're going to look they will look
a little bit different the test loss
would be different from the training
loss so test loss maybe look like
something like this
maybe okay let me draw something I'll
come to my figure so that
um
so this is the training loss now test
loss probably look like this
so that means that even though both of
these two Global Minima are
um
are good solutions from the training
loss perspective one of them is better
from the test test performance
perspective Right This Global minimum is
good and Better Than This Global minimum
because the test performance is better
so and in some sense like the
regularization effect is trying to
choose the the right Global minimum
right you want the regularization in
fact to choose the right Global minimum
so so that you can do some type working
or you can encourage certain kind of
models maybe this model is more kind of
like ellipses so this model has more
Norm than this model so that's why you
prefer this one so if you use explicit
regularization what you do is that you
you're going to say I'm going to change
the tuning loss I'm going to add
something to prefer this one than this
one I'm going to reshape the tuning logs
right that's what the explicit
regularization would do but the implicit
regularization we'll do is the following
so if you consider an algorithm that
optimizes for example suppose you have
you run algorithm this algorithm which
is always initialized this is
initialization
and you do green in this set so you're
gonna
do something like this
and it converts to this one
so so this algorithm will only Converse
to this one but not this one
just because you initialize at this far
right
right so that is kind of in some sense a
preference to convert to This Global
minimum
over this Global minimum because your
algorithm somehow prefer one Global
minimum than the other just because your
algorithm has some certain specifics
right so the initialization make it to
prefer to converge this one
and and there could be other kind of
effects for example if you
um use you know bigger step sets maybe
you are more likely to converts to this
one maybe or maybe vice versa you know
depending on on kind of like the
situations right so this is a very
illustrative thing with one dimension
then you don't really have a lot of like
flexibility here but if you have a very
very complex thing then if you run
different algorithms different algorithm
will converge to different Global
minimum and that preference to certain
type of global minimum is in some sense
is a regularization effect
um so so that you don't converge to
arbitrary Global minimum
um does it make some sense
you said so how does like having a large
number of parameters ensure that it
initializes at that point
yeah I I was I was silent on that in
some sense like I didn't really say why
the initialization has to be here like
this is a active area of research so
what we are sure about is that the
algorithm could have this effect the
algorithm could possibly
um prefer certain kinds of global
minimum than the others but why it would
prefer which kind of global minimum we
don't exactly know for certain kind of
like toy cases we know but for uh for
the general cases we don't I'm going to
show you one cases where we actually can
say what does the algorithm prefer to do
but that's very very simple case for
General case I think the the research
this is still very open research on
question
I saw two other questions here
this seems like of the authorizer is
keeping a number of problems it doesn't
quite necessity
no no here that no no the what do you
mean by the name optimizers
the access is the value of the parameter
it's just they only have one parameter
I'm just I'm joining the the landscape
of the pyramid and I can only Draw
Something in one dimension so so so this
is the value of the parameter you are
just tuning in this parameter you are
doing good instant and this is the loss
surface
so so it does depend on where you
initialize right so if you initialize at
different places you're going to
converge different Global minimum and
and they may have different
generalization effects
different algorithms and then just
choose the one that has the best
performance that's pretty much the right
to do um of course there are some I'm
going to discuss this you know but uh
more detail later but but you know
basically you know
like you can have some intuition where
you have you know the theoreticians have
tried to understand you know what kind
of like algorithms can help
generalization but I think the
conclusion at least so far is not no no
like it's very far from conclusive they
can give you some intuition but they are
not going to be like predictive you know
I don't just tell you like what to do so
you still have to try a lot yeah so yeah
going back to this you know this is just
one dimension you know another way to
think about is that if you can think of
like a two-dimensional question for
example you are skiing in the in the in
a ski resort right so your objective is
basically
minimizing your like uh you're trying to
go downhill right that's your objective
so and and this key result probably have
a lot of villages right like that you
can eventually go home there are
multiple parking lots right so so you
you like in some sense you are saying
that you know one of these parking lot
is great right so this one of this
parking lot is really where they are so
you want to go to that one
um so so diff but but uh but different
algorithm would lead you to do diff to
convert to different uh different
parking lots right so for example
someone is doing very fast skin then
when you do it that you cannot go to
those kind of small Trails so then you
lead you go to one of the parking lot
and some other one prefers like um a
wider kind of like trails and then you
go to the other parking lot so so
different algorithm will lead to lead
you to different parking lot and
different parking lots have different
generalization performance eventually
so
um so this is the high level um
intuition so I'm going to
um let's see
I'm going to discuss a concrete case
which
um
which will also be part of a homework
question so this concrete case uh just
to give you a concrete sense of how this
could even be possible so I'm going to
show you the high level thing and there
are some mathematical part which will be
in the homework so this is the linear
this is a in a linear model
so interestingly even though this
implicit requisition effect
was mostly discovered after deep
learning uh start to be kind of like
powerful but actually you can still see
it in linear models and that's how
researchers start to do research so
um so so let's say suppose we are just
in the most vanilla linear model setting
where you have some under data points
this is just the the trivial linear
regression and your loss function is
something like just the L2 loss the
screen squared error
something like this you have a linear
model but let's say let's make the the
the one different thing is that we
assume n is much smaller than d
so you have very few examples and a very
high dimension so what is d d is the
dimension of the data
and the N is the number of examples I'm
going to assume only is much smaller
than b
so this is over parameterized you have
multiple Global minimum while you have
much so first of all you have multiple
Global minimum
why because they are I'm claiming that
they are minus Theta such that
minus Theta satisfies
y i is equals to Theta transpose x i for
all I
why because you know how many equations
here you have right so so if you want to
so this is the equation to make training
loss zero which is means Global minimum
right so if you have all of this
equality then it means you are either
Global minimum of this training loss and
why there are multiple status such that
you can satisfy this that's because you
can count how many equations they are
right so there are any equations
right and D variables
and these are linear equations right so
so I guess the linear algebra tells us
that if you have any equations T
variables and if n is less than I think
if n is less than D or D minus one I
think only is less than D then uh you're
gonna have at least one solution and if
any is much much smaller than D then you
have a Subspace of solutions and that's
called the uh the what's the the kernels
of the anyway you have a Subspace of
solutions
um uh for for this kind of linear system
equations
right so
um and that's why you're gonna have much
for Global minimum of the chaining
blocks because the entire Subspace of
solutions are Global minimum of the
tuning loss so the question is which one
you're going to converts to right so
which one your Optimizer will will
choose
so it turns out that you know if you use
a good InDesign with zero initialization
then you are going to choose the one
with the minimum L2 naught so here is
the claim
so the claim is that
if you do good in distance
with initialization
Theta is zero
uh this will converge to
uh the minimum Norm solution
so what does the minimum solution mean
formula it means that you converts to
a solution with the smallest L2 Norm
among
those Solutions such that
those global minimum of the loss
function
so
so we use green designs you are not only
just finding a Theta such as the loss
function zero right so typically when
you think about optimization the
optimization is trying to find a
solution such that the loss function is
minimized right that's true you still
find you definitely find a solution such
that the loss function is minimized but
you also have you actually have a tight
breaking effect among the solutions such
that the Optimus the loss function is
minimized you actually choose the one
with the smallest L2 naught
so guys you know in some sense you know
the kind of intuition is the following
so I'm going to try to draw this this is
a little bit
um I need to try to draw this well
um
so suppose you have a
suppose let's say the intuition is that
supposed to let's say you have n is one
um and
say these three
so you just have one equation one linear
equation
and
um so and you have like three variables
so that means that the family of
solutions is a two dimensional Subspace
so
make sure to draw this
okay
okay so so here the Subspace I'm drawing
here is
this is the family of theta such that
you satisfy that the loss is zero right
this is the Subspace
right so you have a substrate Solutions
and but which solution you converge to
that's the question
it turns out that
if you
if you start with let me see what maybe
I will write here
um
it turns out that you're going to find a
solution such that
this is the solution of the fund this is
the solution
drawing this is a little bit challenging
I guess
how did I do this I think I did this
so so you consider that you project zero
to this Subspace right so that you find
this point this point is the the
solution with the minimum knob that is
closest to zero among on the Subspace
and this is the solution that you you
will find you're not going to find other
Solutions with good in descent on
um with initialization zero
so basically that's the claim the claim
is that you're going to find this
particular solution but not the other
Solutions
and the reason is actually fundamentally
reason it's pretty simple like
especially if I draw it in this way of
course if you want to prove it it's a
little bit more complicated
um so the reason is really just that
you start with zero
this is uh where you start with right we
need that and you have a property such
that
when you how do I
um
you need a series this
so you have a property such that if you
start with
if initial is zero right and then at any
time
so uh your Theta is always in the span
of all the data points here I'm gonna
have actually one data point so I'm only
so
um so so basically your Theta cannot
move arbitrarily in any places you only
have you have a restriction on where the
setup can go so actually for this
particular case what happens is really
just that you are just moving it along
this direction
and here you'll find this point that has
the Subspace and that's what the
gradient design is doing so green in
design will not do something like this
will not converge to here it will not
converge to here it will just go
directly go to this this mean this
closest point where the point that is
closest to zero on the Subspace
so so this is this is probably a
property of the optimizers right you can
imagine you may have optimized other
Optimizer suppose you design some crazy
Optimizer which does this or does this
then you will convert to a different
points but if you use Golden design
you're going to do this
you show that green inside is doing this
is just by saying that the good instant
is always in a soft the span of the data
I think this is uh this is actually
something we have we have approved for
in the kernel
kernel uh lecture I'm not sure for a
different purpose you know it's not for
this purpose remember that in a kernel
lecture we try to show that your
parameter is always in a linear
combination of the data and and then
there the purpose was that you want to
represent it by the betas in that
lecture so it's a different reason but
it's different on goal but it's the same
fact right your status is always in a
span of the of the data
[Music]
is defined to be the all the solutions
that have zero loss so these are all the
spelling is that's my definition of the
Subspace this is the family of solutions
that have zero training loss
so and the question is which one I'm
gonna convert to in kind of like I was
arguing that you know they're much for
Global minimum right so this whole spine
is our Global minimum all of them are
Global minimum and which my own converts
to so so different algorithm probably
would convert to different points
so if you run cooling design you're
going to converts to one particular one
in this in this bag
right but but this
um um this this phenomenon also shows up
in other cases but it's going to be you
know much more kind of complicated like
like I think they are only a very
limited number of situations where we
can theoretical proof where you converge
to
um but but it's almost always the case
that the optimizer has some preferences
the optimizer will not converge to
arbitrary zero training loss solution it
will converge to one particular zero
General solution and sometimes that
solution just to General is much better
than the other ones
[Music]
so um
so it's not only one or linear models or
right so so this so only for linear
models the final of zero zero loss uh
solution is a spot right so if you have
non-linear models then the family of
solutions
satisfying this wouldn't be a spot maybe
it's a manifold something some other
weird structure uh right so so in that
sense this is very special
Solution that's gonna be in that's bad
it's going to be the constraint
optimization problem that we just saw
that like it's going to constraint
itself to this like minimizing a second
right right so so I didn't show you the
full proof so this point turns out to be
the point that you converts to turns out
to be the the minimum solution
and it turns out that you actually just
going straight at least for this at
least one case so you know not it's
actually it's not even always true that
you are going in a straight line like
some but uh but you always go in this
Subspace
um so
I'm answering the question maybe I
didn't um
can you prove that yeah you you can
prove that prove it yeah I think the
homework question I actually asked that
you're gonna converts this this Pawn is
exactly the minimum normal solution and
also you're going to convert to that
oh okay
actually you can have a actually you can
have a pretty concrete
representation of this point right it's
really just some inverse some of the
Matrix times something you can you can
compute what exactly is and and you can
show you converge to the point
um I'm not sure whether the homework
asks you to so I think the homework has
to show both
but we will have a lot of hints you know
along the way it's not going to be
interested show this that's it
and maybe for example another just to
give you a sense on you know what these
kind of things can change right supposed
to initialize here then you wouldn't
converge to here so you probably would
convert to somewhere here
and you know and so uh and if you use
stochastic reading is that you probably
wouldn't commercial exactly here either
your power will convert to some
somewhere definitely so so so where do
you exactly converts to it it's it's a
very hard question we don't really know
uh we only know that this this the only
thing we know right now I think formula
is that this matters if you use
different algorithmic cucumbers
different solutions and different
solutions generalize differently so you
have to consider the effect of the
optimizers
and going back to this the reason here
is really so I guess like a this in some
sense this kind of is trying to explain
why you can you can challenge here
that's because because of this implicit
requisition effect even though like you
don't have regularizers you still
implicit regularized L2 Norm so and
that's why in this regime even though
you have a lot of parameters but
actually you are still implicitly
regulating out norm and if you look at
the norm the norm would look like this
so this is the norm as you change the
parameter
so so basically this is saying that when
you have a lot of parameters actually
your real Norm is actually relatively
small and that's why you can generalize
so um so so the the the
reason why you don't generalize in the
middle is because this minimum normal
solution is not actually doing well in
the middle for some other reason so
um so the norm actually turns out to be
big but actually the norm is very small
in the over parametric 3G even though
you use a lot of parameters
thank you
Okay so
so now let's talk about you know
um how do you really do um how do you
really find out what's that you know
I've told you that we don't know too
much about you know what how does the
optimizer uh change things right so we
also don't know exactly how does the
model complexity uh uh change things
right so you only know some intuitions
right so you know that if you have more
complexity it turns out to be more
likely to
over fit but you don't know exactly what
is the right complexity right so how do
you find out the right model the right
optimization algorithm the right you
know regularizer all of this where you
have so many decisions where you
probably have like 10 decisions you have
to make in this machine learning
algorithm so how do you find out what's
the what's the best thing so so I think
the the typical way is just that you are
user uh validation set to
um to figure out what's the best
decision
so
maybe just to motivate that just briefly
so the the easiest way to do is that you
just use a test set right so you have
some test set and you just you try all
kind of algorithms all kind of models
all kind of like a regularization
strength and you see which one has the
best performance uh tested
so that's okay as long as you only use
one you only use the test set at the end
right so to try all of this algorithm in
advance you know you you and then you
collect some test the site or maybe you
collect the test set before but you
never touch it right so that's okay so
you you so you if you only use the test
test once then you can use the tester to
evaluate the performance of all possible
algorithms all possible kind of like
models uh you you want to use
so so that's that's that's that's that's
that's a good thing so however the
problem is that sometimes
um you like you
um you want to do this iteratively you
want to look at a test set and see what
the performance is and then you go back
to say okay maybe I'll change my model
size right or maybe I'll change my uh uh
like my Optimizer right so maybe I'll
change from Green instant to stochastic
in science maybe I want to add some
regularization effect I add some
regularization on like a function so
um
um so if you want to do with iteratively
then the what I said before was not
going to work that's because you know
so typically if you have a test set this
you can only use it once
so because if you use it multiple times
what happens is that you are you could
kind of like overfit to the test set so
basically the your later decision
becomes kind of like a over 3 are our
decisions over fitting to the test set
you have seen before so so the only the
validity of the test type is only
insured when you only suggested after
you you do the tuning so and if you see
the test set and then you like uh you
you do the training and then you test it
again then the second time you test on
test that it will be not guaranteed to
be valid so you may all over a fit to
the test set so does it make sense
I'm trying to be not over complicated
this right so that's why I'm trying to
use informal words for it but if
there's any questions right so so how do
we all deal with this right so the test
set we can only use it once or at least
we can only use it we cannot use it
interactive interactively you can also
see the test stats tune and then see
your tester get set again so so one way
to deal with this is that you um
you
um
you you have a whole doubt or you have a
validation set so so basically you split
the data
into a three part so one part is called
training site
and one part is called validation set
and also test that
and for test start this is your kind of
like uh this is a very you have to be
like a very careful about it you
shouldn't touch touch it this test that
is only only about the very very and you
are using a test set to evaluate your
performance
so and but the validation side this you
use this to tune
hyper parameters
and by hyper parameters here I mean all
the
kind of like the type of parameters that
you are you are choosing for example the
the batch Stars you know the the the
Lambda in the regularization uh maybe
the the choice of the optimizer the
number of neurons you're going to use in
the in deep learning in your deep
learning model
um how long you have you're going to
train in all of these you know decisions
um that you are going to decide in the
in this process they are called hyper
parameters and so you're using mobile
edition set to tune the hyper parameters
and you are using the chain inside to
tune the real parameters right by the
to optimize the parameters right so I
guess typically we don't know so to tune
the parameters
right these parameters are just a
numerical numbers right in the model
which anyway you don't know what where
the meanings are but the hyper
parameters are those kind of things that
you uh you know their meanings right
batch size learning rate step size right
so they all have some meanings uh and
you want to use this validation set to
tune the hyper parameters
so so basically the kind of process is
that you start with the tuning and then
you you valid you start with training
with some hyper parameters and then you
validate on your performance uh and then
you go back to to tune again maybe using
some other hyper parameters and then you
do this iteration for many times
so and after you do all you are done
with everything and you find out a model
that you are happy with which you know
by your happy with you I mean that you
found another model that is very good on
a validation set then you finally test
your model on test set and that can be
only done worse so so in some sense I'm
not sure how many of you have for
accounts in this kygo computation right
it's kind of structured exactly like
this so there is this online platform
where people release their data sets for
and set up some kind of kind of like
challenge for people to submit their
machine in the model to solve their
tasks so basically you know kygo
competition so they have a like the
organizer I have a test set which nobody
can touch at all like this test side is
only the it's only used once at the very
end when you decide who is the winner
so but and then the the the the
organizer released
these two actually I'm not sure
sometimes they give you a division right
so they say this is advantage that this
is the training side sometimes they just
released the total
um all of them to you and then you can
you can divide yourself you know even
the release in this format you can
re-divide them you know whatever you
want to do so let's say suppose you have
divide your you know all the training
example into these two sets you can do
whatever kind of like
um whatever kind of like uh optimization
uh you want so and I think typically
they do have like a desk in the
validation side which is used to for the
for computing the scores on the
leaderboard whether there's a
leaderboard which kind of like tells you
how well you are doing against others at
least temporarily right so so that's the
validation side that's that's evaluate
on the validation side but this
leaderboard may not be exactly uh the
same as the final rank it's possible
that you know finally you found out that
somebody is succeeding in the
leaderboard but eventually in a very
final test
um the the performance is not like as
the validations I suggest
so so but but this is the general setup
that people are doing
um
does it make sense
so one common question you know that
people kind of like generally ask you
know which I ask myself as well is that
you know how how reliable this
validation site is
right so like a like if you have very
high performance on the valuation side
should you trust yourself
so on one side you shouldn't trust
yourself you know 100 because if if you
can trust the organization side
performance why you need to test that
well the test stat is supposed to give
you the final verdict in success right
it's it's a very uh like a it's a
guarantee it's something that guarantees
to give you the right answer so so the
value set is never 100 you know you
probably shouldn't 100 trust it so on
the other hand in Prior college so
people realized in the last five years
that I think there is a sequence of
paper on this people realize that
actually the validation side performance
you know is actually well card with the
test set like so this is a reasonable
indicator about how good your
performance is on Tesla it's just not
there's no theoretical guarantee that
these two are exactly the same so but
but in most of the cases if you don't do
anything crazy you don't kind of like a
somehow just memorize the entire
validation Side by creating some kind of
like um some kind of like uh like lookup
table kind of things then typically a
validation size performance the
performance and radiation set is kind of
very close to test that and this has you
know there is a there's a very um
important paper in the probably three or
four years ago
um by Berkeley people so they actually
look at them
like maybe 300K gold competitions and
and they are like they look at the the
best performance you know the the the
rank of the performance on the
validation side on the leaderboard and
they look at how they correlated with
the the final winner the final
performance and they found that they are
very correlated so which suggests that
the validation side is actually a pretty
good indicator for test set even though
it's not guaranteed
um and any and in this case the typical
machine the uh the typical machine
learning kind of practice is that you
know if you look at the the
um the
um
um like the the when people publish
papers right so in some sense people
publish results based on validation
search
um so for example if you look at image
United performance in some sense people
are uh like the the so-called test
performance that people report is
actually it's actually a performance on
a validation side because that that
so-called test set of has been seen so
many so many times is I think actually
it's lit uh I don't know exactly whether
there's a label like name for it like in
the image not uh the official data set
but at least that's that you know that
you report your performance
um with that side shouldn't be
considered as a test set because test
that you should only use it once but
actually people have used it so many
times maybe a million times so so so
basically
abstract speaking I think these days
when you publish paper you use the
validation set only when you have the
Kegel computation you use the tester to
really decide the winner
but but empirical it sounds like they
are very close so so actually that's why
we are not worried too much about it
any questions
oh I think it's this is a
[Music]
I think it's called hey go or kaigo I
don't know how to be an artist uh this
is a platform so the platform hosts a
lot of computations maybe like um
a hundred every year or something like
that you can submit your model and
sometimes there is a kind of like there
is a price uh for winning the the
competition
so
um right
and by the way I think this validation
is that sometimes now people call it
development site as well
um I don't know how popular this name is
uh but at least if you say but addition
said I think everyone would know what
you're talking about development side I
think most people would know as well but
it's a relatively new term in the last
five years
trading certain validation sets as part
of like a bigger so like once it's
actually decided on what type of
parameters you want to use
right so how do you how do you do the
split right so so here um so the most
typical way is that you just split
randomly you reserve probably a tenth of
the data set as validation size maybe 20
you know depending on how many data you
have so
um and I think what you are probably
thinking is the so-called cross
validation which does something much
more complicated you can kind of split
your data set into uh you can do
multiple splits and try multiple
experiments on different splits so
um I think uh
um
I I think I'm not going to cover it uh
for this lecture mostly because I think
these days if you have a large enough
data set typically you just do this
static spelled just because it's much
easier you don't have to run your
algorithm multiple times and this is
just almost like the
like like in most of the larger scale
machine learning situations you just use
this so but if you just have like 100
examples then indeed as you said you
know if you fix like 20 examples that's
validation side it's a little kind of
like wasteful so then you have to do
some cross validation so we have a we
have a kind of like a section in lecture
notes about cross validation
um there's a there's a description of
the the of the Practical
um I think you know if you're
interesting you can you can read it it's
nothing very complicated either
thank you
okay so I got some
um yeah so I'm gonna use the last
tournaments to talk about some more
um applied perspective
um I'm gonna use the slides so I guess
I'll
see that this can work
okay great so uh
it's not censored is it
wait
okay sounds good
um okay good so um so so I think this
lecture um um so we're talking about
some ml device so um I think I
um so here on these slides are made by
our other instructor crispy uh with the
help of Alex Radner
um I'm pretty much just repeating uh
whatever
um he's saying in the slides
so
um I think the slides you know used to
be a little bit longer than this I'm
going to release the longer version as
well so I shorten it you know to only 20
minutes or 30 minutes
um and part of the reason is that I
think slides also contains something
that has been covered on the Blackboard
on the Whiteboard and also part of the
reason is that there are some applied
Parts on which uh I think we don't have
a lot of time to discuss in
um in this quarter so but I'm going to
release the the longer slides as well
for your reference so so so so this set
of slides are mostly for kind of like a
little bit more applied kind of like
situations for example you are thinking
that you are for example your startup
and you are doing machine learning to
solve some concrete problems right so um
so it's a little bit less like a
research because you know you're gonna
see that you're gonna have more much
more issues than a concrete research
setting right in research actually you
sometimes also have this right in
research the most typical setting is
that you probably have a con very
concrete data set right you know that
the input output you know everything
there's no any room in flexible you
cannot redefine the problem and you just
want to get the best number that's one
type of research I don't think this is
the most typical one either right like
but um but this is one type of research
and then from there you can have more
and more flexibility you can change your
data you can refreeze your problem you
can find out what's the right problem
and and once you really do it in in
Industry then it's going to be you know
much more complicated
so some disclaimers to start with I
think this is Chris disclaimer which is
also mine so these are you know like
there's no Universal kind of like what
is ground shoes here right so there's no
ground shoes it's really just some
experiences and some
um uh some experiences from people doing
right you know in real life
so
um and and things change you know over
time sometimes people thought that was
the right thing to do in five years ago
and now things changed so I'm going to
go through this a little quickly so um
you know
um so um but you know some I'm gonna
omit some of details as well but feel
free to stop me
um
right so
so there are many
um
so in some sense there are many phases
of IML project if you really do it in
Industry right so so for example one
thing you want to discuss is that you
really need ml system even to start with
right some of the questions are not
really necessarily suitable for ML I
think at least I knew I'm not I don't do
as much industry uh work you know as um
you know Chris is also entrepreneur
besides you know
um a professor
um so uh so he knows a lot about this
but even I know that sometimes you know
people actually when they really uh sell
their product as a ml system but
actually the underlying system is not
really using much ml so sometimes you
don't really need ammo and and and when
you need when you use the ml if it
doesn't work you know what you do so and
uh and and also like you know how do you
deal with all the kind of ecosystem
so and when I use the runner example you
know we're going to have a Spam detector
and the question is how do you know
detect spams
um
um you know we'll use this example a lot
in this like in this course so
this is the seven steps for ML system so
here again it's more a little broader
than just the ml research right so
you're thinking about designing a system
that can actually work in practice so
um so acquire data and you want to look
at the data you know and maybe you want
to create some kind of like twin
development test set as we discussed you
want to um Define our refund
specification which I'm going to
discussing in some sense this is saying
that you have to have a evaluation
metric for for your model in what sense
you want to you want your model to
succeed and then you want to build your
model and try a bunch of models maybe
you are going to spend a lot of time in
step five and then you're eventually
you're going to measure uh models
performance you know not necessarily
only according to the specification you
have defined in step four but maybe
you'll have like other match
measurements for example speed training
time so and so forth and then eventually
you have to repeat and maybe you have to
repeat a lot of times
so
um I'm going to go through these steps
you know relatively quickly I only have
like 15 minutes so but you can kind of
like
um if you're interested you can look at
a longer slides as well so
um supposed to say um you want to decide
what is Spam or not
so
so ideally you want a data sample from
the data that your stump product will be
around right so you want to have your
data to be somewhat kind of like closer
to the the final test data right so you
don't want to just collect some spam
data from 30 years ago and then and use
this data to choose something that's
that can work not these days but
sometimes this is not always available
because you never know what what the
spam emails will be 10 years after so
you have to make some sacrifice
um you know sometimes you don't even
have the features you know it may be
like your existing record didn't save
everything maybe it just saves the title
of the email didn't save the the entire
content then that would limit your
capability of detecting spec and there
are many legal issues to look at the
data
um and this is according to crazy you
know I think this is true as well so
you're getting wrong on the first try
right so like sometimes you like you'll
find out that the data you collect are
not the right one you have to repeat
and then you know after collect some
data you have to look at them right so
and this is something that we actually
don't really teach a lot you know in in
this machine learning course looking at
your data right because you know we are
mostly assuming that you already have
your data you you make the right
assumption already you already know your
data is gaussian and then you uh you you
are engaging discriminated analysis
right but we never say how do you how do
you decide whether you you really make
the Assumption of the about the gaussian
Assumption so but in practice you have
to do that because you have to
um uh see whether data makes sense you
know there are many nuances there for
example sometimes your data are not as
good as you think maybe there are some
kind of like um maybe the format is not
right maybe there's some kind of like
outliers
um so and so forth and and only if you
look at the data you cannot see uh
what's what's going on there so I
actually you know even research
sometimes I experience this right so
like I think in one of my projects
um like uh I think we use we just use
the wrong data from day one in some
sense I think the data like some of the
data will just crafted you know just by
accident and we are tuning on them and
until only until like
um like one month I think we realized
that so of course in research it's
probably easier to tack that you know
one month is a long time for us to
detect it I think but but actually you
know you can easily detect them but for
for real life cases you know sometimes
it's even harder for example you don't
even necessarily have the tools to look
at look at your data you maybe have to
build some tools to look at your data
and and you need to kind of like think
about different subpopulations maybe
spams from edu emails or spams from.com
emails and and see uh what are the
differences so this will give you a lot
of intuitions on you know what data you
should use and our Workshop models uh
you should use and and do this at every
stage because you know like um in for
example we will really do them
and this is also while the reason why
you want to build some tools to look at
data conveniently right so sometimes
like if you just look at it once then
sure then you can just uh maybe print
out something right so but if you want
to look at many times then you should
have some convenient tools which
actually eventually will reinforce and
let you to more likely to to look at
data right so I think at least in
research I I also realized this so if
the data is very hard to visualize then
people are less likely to
to to visualize the data so so sometimes
it requires an investment so that you
can
um you can have this tool so that in the
future you are you have less of um uh on
um kind of like cost to look at your
data and you should do this at every
stage uh in many cases
um
so and and this is um I guess you know
this is about domain knowledge where you
sometimes you know some of the data
requires expertise right like
um to know so so some I think there are
there are some examples you know in the
slides which I uh removed just to save
some time but like in short and
sometimes you know for example if your
data is crowded like experts only
experts can know like a like for example
you have medical data only experts can
know that your data are crafted but like
from a machine learner
um perspective the data looks fine
so I will talk about children depth on
tester split so um so this of course is
something important for you to
um to do
um and in practice you know it's other
lesson
um clear
um than uh than in research right
because in research you already got
sometimes you already got a split even
at the first place right so before like
you got a data the data already has a
split but in real life sometimes you
have to avoid certain kind of like
leakage uh so for example maybe
sometimes for example let me take an
extreme case right so suppose your data
has reputations so if you have like a
million data but actually it's just a
two like every data points is repeated
twice so essentially you just have 500k
and but repeat it twice if that's the
case then you split the data then you're
going to see some reputations between
like you some examples in the test will
also show up in the training exactly the
same
so that would be disasters so so you
have to kind of avoid some situations
and this actually happens in in the
Kegel context so actually in many in
many many
like exactly like I actually I I try to
do some of this Kegel contacts at some
point at least at that time like that's
probably three or four years ago
um maybe maybe more than four years
maybe six years ago at that time many of
the contest so if you look at them
there's some always some kind of like
forum for discussions discussing like uh
uh
okay
[Music]
like I think I'm sure this happens more
in the industry which I'm not less
familiar with but in even in the Kegel
contest so
um so in many of the Kegel context if
you look at the Forum always after like
a half like a like a half a month I mean
after a few weeks someone will figure
out some leakage but just because you
know something examples are very very
close to test example so that they just
use this leakage uh to to hide the
number so it's kind of like some kind of
like weird rule so that you can make the
validation performance much better than
you thought and and everyone has to use
that and it's kind of interesting I
don't know why it's like everyone who
found this kind of late cage they always
post it in the Forum somehow and and
then ever I don't know whether this is
always true but like for the few cases
I've seen they do this and then everyone
else will have to use this small Gadget
to improve their model performance
because if you don't use it your model
performance is just not as good as
others
um
so yeah I don't know whether they now
they have maybe they have some better
ways to to detect this leakage to design
the computation much better
um I don't know so but this is something
you have to pay attention you know um in
practice and also another kind of tricky
thing is that what is a good spirit so
we have discussed whether you should do
random splits right so in research as I
said you know random side is pretty much
the best way you can do because you
really literally care about uh the
validation performance but
um but the problem is that
um sometimes you know uh in the real
world
like your test you like your the the the
the test data set is actually not really
what you care about so
um so so that's why when you split it
you also want to split the the children
validation set in a way such that the
validation set is
some of the closer to the real test set
let's so I guess this is the situation
so suppose you say you are thinking
about stock price prediction
right so so your final goal is to
predict the price
in the future
right so that's something you just don't
have at all right so and and so now
suppose you have data between
um 2020 or 200 2020 right so you have
these 20 years of data so how do you do
the tune uh uh validation split should
you just just do a random split or you
should do some other things so one
possible option is that you should
probably split into for example 2000 to
2015. that's the tune and to 2015 to
2020 that's the validation why you argue
that why that's a possible option
um possibly just because the last five
years is more predictive of the future
than the the earlier years
so you know I don't I don't necessarily
say I'm not necessarily saying that this
is the the only option or the best
option but this is at least something to
consider right so this was kind of like
a kind of like a um this is not what we
do in research just and the reason is
just because you know like you care
about the performance in the future
which is something you don't have access
to
right
so I guess this is a
right so the better split is they use
the first 50 days to predict the last 50
days
so um okay and create a specification
right so so I think this is mostly
related to like how do you kind of like
Define what you want to predict and and
what's the what's the kind of the goal
right so are you so in many cases you
can use Machine model in many different
ways uh uh from uh from from what you
wanted to use it right so and also you
care about kind of different
um kind of like uh perspectives for
example you know what is a spam right so
like the definition of spam sometimes
you know are different
um between different people right so
like um maybe do you think like an ad
right from some from from say Google do
you think that's that as a spam you know
maybe I always think of like that but
some something else probably prefer to
receive some emails some add emails with
very low rate right so so you have to
specify exactly what you want to predict
right so what is really the definition
of span and you don't want to have
ambiguities at least you know from
this day's perspective right so like a
machine learning models don't like
ambiguities you really want to have a
clear cut what is the spam what is not
and and also like a what level of
expertise is hard to understand it
because you know if you specify the spam
you know you can have a definition but
if your labeler don't are not able to uh
label the spam according to your
definition is not going to be useful
right suppose you have a very very
complex definition of spam and then you
say I have this data and I'll ask
laborers to label them but the laborers
cannot execute my definition of spam
easily that's going to be another issue
and and also the specifications like uh
um so you use the specification you want
because you want to kind of like a uh uh
on you use the specification to define a
set of examples right so because
eventually if you just have a some kind
of description text description about
what is a spam that's probably not
useful you have to really have a set of
test examples and the test examples have
labels and that's is really your
definition of span
so and for example one of the quick and
dirty tests here is that
um
what are your definition of the span
um can pass this so-called you know
inner annotated agreement so basically
what you say is that you write down some
definition and then you select a some
randomly selected or you get some
examples of emails and then you ask
um three annotators to see whether they
can agree on which email is a spam or
not according to the definition you give
them and often you don't really get that
high of agreement you know you know you
don't get 100 agreement you know in many
cases you know people's interpretation
of the same definition would be
different
um and let's say you know you have 95
agreement I think that's already
considered to be great
and then you have 95 of agreement then
the question becomes you know whether uh
uh it's meaningful to shoot for some
accuracy more than 95 right if the
annotators don't agree with each other
uh um only agree with each other on 95
percent of 95 of time
actually sometimes you can do better
than that just because humans are
sometimes you know lesson
um
have less in accurate like
interpretation or sometimes machine
models can do better but you know
typically you probably shouldn't shoot
for much higher than 95 in many cases
so um
and and then you know you're gonna you
know do this iteratively for example you
have to kind of examine the
specifications you gotta look at you
know what's the discouragement you know
why you have discouragement maybe that
means you have changed your
specification and
um and and and you know and the last
question is kind of interesting what do
you tune the people on the machine
eventually at some time if you kind of
have a lot of like a different
um sometimes you have to tune the people
to label them correctly right so for
example even like the image
classification problem we have this
clearly defined labels right so dog cats
you know but once you go to the the more
the the the breeze of godox right so
some some of the laborers don't really
recognize different breeds of dogs so
you have to tune the labelers uh in some
way so I have a friend who did this like
a in PhD and and basically he has a lot
of kind of training documents for the
labelers you know Amazon account workers
and and I I they have to actually ask
the Turkish to pass some exams to be
able to to be a labeler for them so so
so it's actually kind of complicated
okay so I guess I'll I'll be quick given
that we are almost running all the time
so and then when you do the model this
is the more machine learning part so you
want to implement the simplest possible
model so
um and you keep it simple and then
um um and sometimes I think this is the
this thing so don't get embarked on new
models uh use them to understand data
right so sometimes like a
um the problem is that
um the models are not only the angle
sometimes you know you want to use the
model to understand uh what are the
problems with the data right so and and
sometimes you can you can fix the data
and then the model becomes the
performance becomes much better so
um so this this is a whole Loop right
your bottleneck may not just be only
about the model sometimes it could come
from some other places maybe a data
maybe a specification maybe the chin
test split so and so forth
and and you have some bass lines so that
you know what you are what you are doing
and you need to do some mobilization
studies on so and so forth
and and then step six you know you need
to match the output so and uh
you have to measure the output so that
you don't you know make mistakes twice
and you want to catch up catch new
mistakes as soon as possible
um and you want to measure kind of
different things and simple things for
example
um like like there are a bunch of kind
of like qualities you care about here
um and and so and so forth
and this is probably one thing that
um
um that we it's one challenge we are
really facing these days about machine
learning model maybe I would say
probably one of the most important
challenges so the reason is that you
have a description shift right so you're
training an validation description are
very different from a distribution that
you will test eventually
um or maybe they are similar but there
is some kind of like special
subpopulations that make them different
right so for example you're tuning on
San Francisco street views a new test on
Arizona street views for example when
you build a automatic autonomous driving
car then you know you tune on some
street views and you have to test on
some other places and that creates a
distribution shift and then uh you can
you can have surprises
and you know there are not so many kind
of like good uh ways to do this you know
except that you have to kind of be
careful about it and these are new
algorithms
um and um
and this is incredibly hard right
there's no real solutions in Industry I
don't think there's real solutions in
um in in research either so I think
we're gonna have for one guest lecture
by James o about the robustness of
machine learning models there are a lot
of recent work on it
um but so far we don't have you know I
think we have definitely better
algorithms to to be more robust but I
think the performance is probably the
robustness is still not
um ideal enough
Okay so
okay I think I'll just jump to step
seven so yeah you have to repeat and
look how data I release the longer
version of the slides you know if you
are interested in some of the details
thanks